house comer as my spirit pack today
we're gonna play your a song generator
we're gonna make a song when we're gonna
sing it together of course we're gonna
choose the best country in the world VIN
numbers I will never betray your Sweden
let's pick the most stereotypical we -
person I don't know all right you know
what let's we have diversity in our
country it's all it's all good there we
go we're gonna make a glam rock and our
song topic will be about cake our
costume is gonna of course be pink and
our accessories glam makeup cuz we fab
in Sweden obviously performance gimmick
lasers cake and lasers this should be
good
Go Go Sweden I hope Sweden win so much
nice outfit whoa those laces what was
the song name yeah me Tom Tommy yummy
cake
tell me yummy yeah kick yeah comma comma
y a cake so yummy Tommy Tommy yummy yeah
cake yeah cake I feel tummy yummy do you
feel
tell me me I can't this is so bad I'm
sorry I'm so sorry I didn't think I
would be this bad so sure Tommy Tommy
and me so better than nothing we were
there we go baby pastry I was pretty
good all right
so Sweden has 12.13.12 points
come on Sweden yeah last last place why
are they holding her vagina let's try
another one that was not very good
which country brace what's that UK all
right then we have this bearded man or
woman I your vision you can never know
it will be 90s dance about
kittens and black leather and sunglasses
with rainbows
this is gonna be great oh my god it's a
girl or boy who knows everybody fluffy
kitten so fluffy fluffy kittens so
fluffy fluffy mr. fluffy fluffy kitty
cat fluffy we're together block a kitty
cat fluffy while I gather Scooby Doo
kitty cats will do amazing amazing that
was pretty good what you love again I
would get so many points I don't
understand I we King old Jesus Christ
they really liked that song didn't they
second place god yeah me that's it
that's a [ __ ] lie
all right which one express what's that
you want me to do get it maybe everyone
knows everyone is ginger in Germany um a
power ballad that sounds good about
sunshine everyone know I have to I want
to people like leather again but I guess
I'll get see thrown yeah what do you
want it's a time for Germany to sink
hold on Edgar
your time will come studded color of
course and the song will be in green
screen
oh how nice haha tournaments in there
are cool and you don't ruin this [ __ ]
Sun for me that dancer the sunshine it's
sunny
oh let's picture oh subject so shiny
Oh
Oh dance to the sunshine sunny oh oh oh
sunshine so shiny sorry Oh rays bad have
a race booty boo me and you you can see
through meiosis and you and me maybe
Terry I was so beautiful I like every
subtly grabs her ass no and really no
judge
Oh God they didn't like this song did
they also now I get it
last place jeez all right which one
should we do next press what what's that
Russia all right then
everyone in Russia looks like this and
this so this will be a 90s disco about
kittens in white leather wearing
headphones and darkness I don't know
what that oh damn this outfit look the
kitchen song with Boris and Anastasia
one two it's kittens for you why I'm
stood occasions it's fluffy
Oh tonight one two it's kitten for you
two names to the kittens is fluffy Oh
scooby-doo Kitty Casper fluffy kitty cat
fluffy well that was [ __ ] - well that
was short all right let's see that was
pretty good
come on give us some points you guys are
just racist against Russia Oh God all
right which one expert which one expert
what's that hey Charlie all right then
this is Italy
I don't want Celtic is let's do that a
Celtic song about the internet new teeth
is severe accessory flying what the [ __ ]
is that
Oh nice outfits we want matrix put your
hands up rose put your hands up for the
matrix we want me one
Digital matrix so did you know oh we won
the drinks one matrix now digital matrix
so did it all a one two three digital
cyberspace are we have space of the
that has to win that was amazing we're
getting some points this time around at
least Malta Thank You friends thank you
yeah we could win this one breast come
on come on come on No so close ah one
more last one oh so no Meah Meah KKK so
come be on the air kick yeah so tummy
tummy yummy you and me
it's pastry for you pastry for me that
was a lot of fun I had a lot of fun
thank you for putting up for me singing
I know it was very beautiful don't lie
don't lie write a comment right now
saying it was beautiful thank you for
liking this video and I'll see you bros
in the next one
stay awesome raffia